vieles spricht dafür dass es den
rätselhaften willing nemesis
tatsächlich die bisher war der stern
der unsere sonne begleiten wollen nur
eine hypothese durch neueste
untersuchung zur sternentstehung wurde
diese allerdings jetzt bestätigt und
das würde nichts gutes bedeuten dann
würde nämlich stimmt dass ich der
stern etwa alle 26 millionen jahre
unserem sonnensystem nähert und ein
riesiges gestein bombardement
verursachte würden dann so viele
einschläge sein dass es ein
massenaussterben auslösen würde gibt
es also nehmen sie es wirklich und steht
uns wieder ein massenaussterben bevor
sie zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
das szenario wäre ein wirklich
unangenehmes denn selbst wenn wir in der
lage wären asteroiden kometen im anflug
zu zerstören
dieses gestein bombardement wäre
dramatisch tausende objekte würden sich
nämlich dann aus der auktion wolke
lösen und ins innere des sonnensystems
zu uns liegen hunderte davon würden auf
der erde einschlagen aber welcher wären
das wäre dann kaum auszumachen wir
könnten diese apokalyptischen einschlag
kaum ausweichen dieses szenario stellten
die paläontologen david emm raub und
invasion der kosten von der university
of chicago in den usa 184 auf die
untersuchten die verschiedenen phasen
des massensterbens auf der erde und
stellten eine periodizität fest alle 26
millionen jahre kam es zu solchen
katastrophen als ursache machten sie
schließlich meteoritenschauer aus um
postulierten damals ein zwillings objekt
der sonne den zwillings der nemesis der
sich alle weg von 20 millionen jahre den
sonnen system nähert und diesen
meteoritenschauer verursacht er aus der
orten wolke um unser sonnensystem stammt
wo der stern gestein staub und eis
körper durch seine gravitation
herausgelöst hat diese arbeit wurde in
der folge heftig diskutiertes wurden
andere ursachen für das
massenaussterben und das regelmäßige
auftreten genug da aber schlussendlich
konnten sich die forscher und
forscherinnen nicht einigen bis heute
aber heute scheint sich das zu ändern
am erst 30 jahre neueste forschung
sprechen dafür dass es tatsächlich
genommen für die nemesis gibt und der
stern hier wirklich regelmäßig vorbei
kommt das ist schon eine irre
vorstellung und auch ein bisschen spooky
dass es tatsächlich ein weiteres
riesiges gestirn geben könnte neben
planet 9 der ja noch gesucht wird das
café zu unserem system dazu gehört und
nur extrem selten auftaucht und dann
auch noch durch schlimme katastrophen
auslöst aber wie kommen die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
jetzt darauf war der wolf vom harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics und
steven taylor von der university of
california in berkeley haben sich näher
mit der sternentstehung beschäftigt und
dabei verblüffende festgestellt dafür
haben wir die daten der radioteleskope
des very large array sin
den usa ausgewertet wie stammten aus der
beobachtung der perseus molekül wolke
die wolke ist eine sternen wie gewohnt
zur zeit zahlreiche sterne entstehen die
zum teil nur 500.000 jahre alt sind und
die jüngsten dieser stern babys sind
nahezu alle ausnahmslos doppelsterne nur
ältere sterne treten auch einzeln auf
und jetzt haben die beiden verschiedene
modelle ausprobiert um zu berechnen wie
oft solche doppel sterne entstehen und
jetzt kommt es wieder das einzige modell
das die perseus beobachtung
reproduzieren konnte war eines in dem
alle sterne ursprünglich als
doppelsterne mit weiten entfernung
zwischen den beiden partnern entstehen
sagt sieben zähler
genauso wie sich bei nehmen sind und der
sonne verhalten würde wie diese sterne
sehr weit voneinander entfernt märz 500
astronomische einheiten
das ist die 17-fache entfernung vom
neptun zur sonne den äußersten
bekannten planeten unseres sonnensystems
und zitat wahrscheinlich gab es vor
langer zeit wirklich eine nemesis mein
fehler
allerdings muss diese these jetzt mit
anderen sternen wiegen bestätigt werden
taylor und sah dabei bin aber
zuversichtlich dass ihre these
bestätigt wird dann haben wir hier aber
wirklich weh zu tun wo ist nemesis ist
dann die frage wie bereiten wir uns auf
einen deutsch dramatischen
meteoritenschauer vor wie geben wir das
wissen an möglicherweise in einigen
millionen jahren hier lebende nachkommen
weiter und so weiter und so fort
aber es gibt einen lichtblick nicht
immer hat laut dieser these nemesis das
massenaussterben ausgelöst zwei mal ist
es ausgefallener sorgt vielleicht kommt
nemesis der ortsmitte nicht immer so nah
dass der stern dieses bombardement nicht
ich bin wirklich wahnsinnig spannend wir
haben also einen neuen himmelskörper
der wahrscheinlich existiert und zu
unserem sonnensystem zumindest mittelbar
gehört und wen wir jetzt suchen die
nähe des suche falls es etwas neues
dazu gibt es natürlich hier wenn er zu
diesem thema auch in der zukunft nicht
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die blogger denn nur dann bekommt
ihr auch eine benachrichtigung wenn ein
neues video online geht hier geht es
weiter mit dem mysteriösen planeten 9
und der suche danach einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran